he is future first ballot hall-of-famer
in the NFL Charles Woodson here on the
Richard show how are you Charles doing
I'm doing great before we get to I guess
what you talked about with epics let's
talk about a couple more more recent
items than the NFL docket first of all
that Monday night game it looked like a
playoff game to me had Bobby Wagner on
the show yesterday talking about the
hits that were delivered in that game
what you're a guy who's played in games
like that did it did it look and feel
like a playoff game to you Charles and
it certainly did and I think Bobby hit
it right on the head when you talk about
physicality of the game and of course
you know what the linebackers doing in
the defensive line offensive line going
at it but I thought one play man
from a veteran corner one of the one of
the best in our game right now Richard
Sherman is getting blocked by Metcalfe I
believe and that came off the line very
aggressive got into Sherman but Sherman
is 40 balls and then Sherman came up and
made to hit and I mean that was that was
probably one of the best hits or tonight
but it came from the cornerback and I
think that that particular play right
there man just kind of showed you what
kind of energy level was involved in
that game right now
right then and I thought that it
definitely had that playoff atmosphere I
think it also had the element of you
know Richard Sherman hadn't been on the
other side and in that locker room
playing with those guys and those guys
having that mutual respect but wanting
to beat each other you know who says so
I thought that game was that was one of
the better games I've ever seen what's
the I agree with you and that's Carl a
lot coming from you right there what's
the most physical game you ever played
in Charles
I think probably anytime we play the
Giants you know I think the Giants
always came with but it was a physical
mindset they were one of the teams I
think they played you know with a more
old-school approach where they would
line up in 21 personnel and you know
they weren't always concerned with you
know going 11 personnel you know one
back one tied and three wide receivers
they would like to line up in the
backfield with Brandon Jacobs and
Bradshaw and they would try to pound you
and so you know you had to tackle those
guys you're a corner yes you had the
yeah the cover you see a man but you had
to come up with maybe five tackles in
the run game so it was always dealing
with with the within New York Giants and
I was that more aware seeing a
photograph review with Chapman Eli but
you're in a Raiders uniform is that
Packers more often than not or what do
you think when you played them
yeah Packers Man playoffs man I had to
see those that see those guys in
playoffs twice and they beat us twice on
the way to the Super Bowl and so you
don't know that those are two games you
know that you wish you could have back
you know one was they're not in the
championship game and they went on to
beat New England the first time and in
the second time playing those guys I
believe in 2011 and they beat us in the
second round we had a bye week I believe
they came into our house twice and beat
us but they they were always of physical
football teams it seemed like no matter
when we played them it was always the
Giants they were always the most local
teams well Charles after that Monday
night game where again Seattle came up
with that huge win they matched both
Green Bay and also now San Francisco
with eight wins somehow someway Atlanta
got off the mat to spank the Saints in
their own building and the Vikings took
care of business in Dallas and so you
got three eight win teams you got to
seven win teams who is the best team in
the NFC right now as we enter week 11 in
your estimation Charles Woodson
that's a tough question you hit me with
man oh I would say out of the team so I
did it that you just mentioned I forgot
it I gotta go I think it's the San
Francisco 49ers a thing right now
I just think because of you know their
defense in the way too deep is the plan
I think that Garoppolo I think it's
taking him some time you know coming off
of that knee injury I still don't think
he's quite as comfortable as he was
before he hurt that knee and but I think
he you know he showed some flashes in
the game the other night where he seemed
like he was you know just starting to
kind of get his feet up under him but
then you know clownin the boy started
heating up the min-sun think he still
needs a little bit more time but i think
with the way their defense is playing
right now with a they're very
opportunistic you've seen those guys
going after the football in the backend
you know creating turnovers but they you
know give Seattle some credit with
Russell Wilson I mean they just got a
great quarterback but I think team wise
I will go with the with the 49ers so is
Russell your MVP as we currently stand
here - who's your MVP
oh man I love what Russell is doing I
give him all the credit in the world but
this young guy Lamar Jackson down there
in Baltimore man I think he is just
turning heads right now with what he's
been able to do this year and in the way
he seems to just be out there kind of
toying with with decencies right now I
think with that team and is Lamar
Jackson doesn't you know turn the ball
over down the stretch and when they get
into the playoffs I think they're
definitely a Super Bowl team and in
their feet if he's able to get that team
to roll in the second half of this
second half of the season the way he's
been doing the last couple of games I
think he wins you know and let's stay on
the subject a little bit Charles because
the concept of the sustainability deep
into January this offense is being
called into question
I guess because Lamar and this offense
got thumped by a Chargers team that
might not make the playoffs this year
what is your stance on the subject of
that offense and the way it's being run
and how viable it could be to win a
Super Bowl this year
I think it's very viable because I think
that you know they're multiple you know
that kind of keeps you guessing with
with all you know different personnel
groupings and you know think about what
makes their often so hard in your own
defense you know you don't account for
the quarterback in the run game you know
so he's an extra Runner and so what's
that what is up happening is you get
next to blocker you know so they run
power run games know with Lamar and with
him after running back which is you know
you don't you know not gonna see from
from every quarterback so it tests your
discipline and then with him his escape
ability is second to none I mean he can
get out of just about any jam he's in on
the football field you know I think that
you combine the run game his escape
ability and the fact that he has gotten
better as a passer I think even other
guys just getting more comfortable in
the NFL and I think he's making better
throws I'm really quick release which i
think is great you know for attribute
for a quarterback to have but like I say
for him it would just be not turning the
ball over and I'm worried about him more
fumbling the ball than I do passing the
ball so if he just takes care of the
football you know from that standpoint
not fumbling I think this team is in the
office and what they do I think they're
they're gonna be a tough out well I mean
the offensive coordinator for Baltimore
is the same offensive coordinator for
Colin Kaepernick that that ended your
Packers career your last game as a Green
Bay Packer was that playoff loss to
Kaepernick and the 49ers what are your
thoughts about Kaepernick's viability as
a quarterback on this sudden arrangement
of a work out by the NFL for Kaepernick
for all 32 teams to attend on Saturday
Charles what do you think about this
news
well I think it's about time you know it
certainly took long enough for a guy
certainly talented enough to play
playing the NFL I think to me the only
thing that hurts him is that he's been
out of the league three years now so you
know what player are you gonna get you
know for a guy who's been on a
three-year hiatus I'm sure you know he's
still relatively young hasn't had the
beating he's gotta take for the last two
years but to go it's a long time not to
be out of the game but also to a thing
just going back to Lamar Jackson and
working with Greg Roman who I believe is
the coordinator who worked with
Kaepernick I think if he is to go to a
team then you have to have somebody like
a Roman that is able to you to utilize
you know what he's good at and a lot of
the things that Tamar Jackson is able to
do they were able to do when Kaepernick
was in San Francisco so okay so now
you're looking at him right now to maybe
bring him into your locker room but what
are you going to do to utilize his
talents and get the most out of contact
happened so with that being said can he
play absolutely I mean we all we've all
seen him play we've seen him take a team
to a championship game see him get to
the you know Super Bowl and didn't win
it but he was able to do those things
he's been a good quarterback in our
league but now having had three years
off what what player are you getting now
so you know kudos for four teams giving
him a look but man they certainly waited
long long enough and perhaps you know
wasted some of these young man's talent
Charles Woodson here on the Rich Eisen
show tonight on epics at 9:00 Eastern
Time NFL the grind you and Ed Reed
converge with bills and browns Wow
what'd you learn about the Browns you
saw the win
they're now three and six what what did
you pick up or glean as to why this team
is three and six as opposed to the
reverse is a lot of people expected
Charles
well you know I had high hopes for the
Browns going into the season I think I
was like a lot of people you know you
know with all of the talent you know
that they were that they have
accumulated onto this football team you
know I expected those guys to come out
come out better you know the first part
of this season but I think you know what
I learned from UM from being there is
they're really young they're it's really
a young team and I think that right now
they don't they don't necessarily know
how to win as a group right now they did
get to get to win I'm a big win for them
on Sunday but I just think collectively
you know they're struggling trying to
figure out you know what we're team is
you know what they have and how to
utilize it I think they're I think
they're looking for a leader on their
team one of those young guys has to
emerge as being the leader that they can
all kind of rally behind and I think for
me you know just being in that short
time to me I think miles Gary can be
that guy I know he's not a very vocal
guy but what I got from him man in the
short time is that you know I was there
for a couple of hours and doing
interviews on the whole night and after
practice is over you know yes go get
inside so I'm there you know a period of
time longer but then when it's time to
do the interview you know there was he
was done with his massage and whatnot he
went right back to the working room
so here you got a young guy man who's 24
years old he could do rest night of the
building to try to get home and through
whatever but he was still in the weight
room still working on his craft still
grind and so I think if they're looking
for you know that type of leader and
that team of somebody to follow I think
miles could be that guy so that's kind
of my vibe something from that that
young Cleveland Browns team and what was
it like hanging with that man
I mean I instagrammed out a photograph
and there you are with your intercept
wine a nice bottle of red popped it open
smoking cigars with with Ed Charles that
was awesome it was epic we had a great
time man we you know what we just you
got two guys man
that played the game for a long time had
a lot of accomplishments but just still
loved to be around the game we just got
to you know talk about you know each
other's careers and you know how you see
you certain things and just kind of have
fun like you said smoke cigars he's big
into cigars I have to wine the intercept
and so it was just it was a fun vibe we
got to hang around young players young
up-and-coming guys hang out at a
football game and just and just enjoy
the moment you know we've been inside
those lines for so long but to be able
to just be at the game be on the
sidelines and watch the young guys go
out there and do that thing was just a
lot of fun for us so what's gonna happen
in Aaron Arbor when Michigan State rolls
into town fresh off of having lost to
Illinois Charles what do you what do you
think is gonna happen this Saturday man
we gotta send them send them home
limping man you know we you know we're
coming off to buy you know but but we're
coming off you know a win and dinner buy
so our guys should be fresh and ready to
go
I feel like our team is you know
starting to start to play better
you know I think collectively you know
they say is it starting to play better
from the way he started you know earlier
in the year you know the team had a lot
of fun balls lot of lost fumbles but I
think people are in agreement that you
know kind of the second half of the Penn
State game you know things you know kind
of started to click a little bit and
then it rolled into the next week so
we're kind of looking at trying to keep
that momentum going into this game
against Michigan State so I am looking
forward to Miskin going out here and
dominating this game well your know not
just not just not just beating Michigan
State but dominating well I mean you're
from the state of Ohio and this is like
brother versus brother or is you know
Hart called it right which created a big
stink and that Dantonio came in and
and kind of flip that script as he was
first taking the job it's kind of been a
little bit different even with that punt
that went awry and our bars first
go-round with this rivalry we've got a
good story about Michigan Michigan State
when you were there about what it meant
or what what you heard about from Lloyd
Carr at the time you got a good one to
give a an example of what this rivalry
means in that state Charles yeah you
know I mean when you get there you know
whenever you get to a university then
you kind of really figure out you know
what it means of course I watched it on
TV as a kid but when you're in the
locker room you know you truly
understand the dynamic of the game and I
think when you look at Michigan Michigan
State you have a lot of guys who are in
state who were high schoolers who got
recruited to one school or the other so
a lot of those guys they really know
each other you know I'm saying they went
to you know play summer leagues together
and different things like that so it's a
little you know different with those
guys and so going into that game I
remember my freshman year but in my 18
19 years old I have these these little
brains that I have in my hair and so you
know I was young and thought I was
pretty tough guy cool or whatnot but I'm
going into this game and they got Derek
Mason I think we'll see mohabbat so they
have some tough receivers out there on
the field and I remember you know we get
into the game it's tough game it kind of
goes down to the wire but late in the
game I believe we were like a cover to
among Derek Mason he comes off the line
I get a little Jam and then I think I
think of 20 banks as a quarterback Tony
banks throws ball I go up to intercept
the ball game is gonna be over I got my
hands on the ball in the ball tipped off
my hands there it makes me catches the
ball it means you know tackling get him
down
but the games almost over no there's
only there's only a few seconds left on
the clock the very next play they throw
a touchdown on the other side of the
field and Michigan State end up beating
us so I so I'm I'm pissed off because I
let down all the
guys on the team that this game meant
something to I went home that night man
and for whatever reason I just cut off
all my braids cut all my hair off and
just went and I just cut it off cut it
out and say you know what that game is
over I'm done with the braids this will
never happen again and that was the end
of that so the entire when you were
stronger that was my fresh meat you were
stronger without the bridge amazing
strong I was talking with Adam when
people need to hear I guess I didn't
need it well just take it from me
Charles you don't need hair don't worry
about it I'm strong I'm stronger without
I think you're Charles like I told you
all fair I'll say it here - you're
you're awesome at being a correspondent
on this show it thrills me that you say
yes every time that you're asked to do
it and I hope you do it some more I
can't wait for everyone to see your work
with that tonight then I appreciate a
man thanks for having me on and
everybody check it out
9:00 p.m. Eastern tonight I have to the
channel that's right me and meaning the
great ed Reed a man you got it an
intercept wine chart check it out
straight genius from Charles one
intercept live.com check it out Charles
titled the Morris hip industry there you
go Charles what's and everybody Charles
Watson everybody thanks thanks to the
call Charles that's at Charles Woodson
on Twitter as well as Instagram for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app